more than 300,000 people have been
displaced from it lipped city and just a
little over a month despite previous
agreements between turkey Russia and
Iran on a so-called de-escalation zone
in this last rebel health area in the
northwest of Syria bombing has
intensified by the Assad regime forces
and his Russian allies eight
organizations have raised alarm about a
deteriorating humanitarian situation
Turkey which has already taken in 3.7
million Syrian refugees is concerned
more will come turkish President Recep
Tayyip Erdogan and Russian President
Vladimir Putin discussed the situation
in Italy when they met in Istanbul on
Wednesday for the launch of a gas
project connecting both nations by
high-tech pipelines but in their
statement on Wednesday there was no
mention of a ceasefire in it lip but
instead they called for a ceasefire in
Libya starting on January 12 meanwhile
in Libya general Khalifa Haftar who was
backed by Russian mercenaries has
rejected the ceasefire proposal there
and it's unclear if the ceasefire in it
Lib will hold since September 2018 more
than 1300 civilians have been killed in
attacks by the Syrian regime and Russian
forces a ceasefire declared on August
31st last year also failed to hold each
of the cease fires just as with every
single agreement that the Russians in
the regime is made the cease fires are
then broken and the regime continues its
brutal military onslaught and we hope
that this time will be different and it
is really Turkey's responsibility here
calls for a ceasefire come at a crucial
time as a UN mandate that allows
humanitarian aid delivery to Syria
through four border crossings is set to
expire on Friday leaving 3.7 million
people vulnerable shoot hostilities
continue step fasten al Jazeera Moscow